bienvenue dans cette série sur la compréhension de l'information et du calcul quantiques, je m'appelle John Watrous et je suis directeur technique de la formation chez IBM
Quantum. C'est la leçon numéro 15 de la série, et c'est la troisième leçon de la quatrième unité, qui porte sur l'erreur quantique
correction. Jusqu'à présent, nous avons vu quelques exemples de codes correcteurs d'erreurs quantiques, notamment le code de Shore à neuf qubit
le code de Steane à 7 qubit et le code à 5 qubit, et nous avons aussi discuté du formalisme des stabilisateurs, qui fourn
nous fournit une base mathématique à partir de laquelle nous pouvons décrire et analyser ces codes correcteurs d'erreurs quantiques et bien d'autres encore
Les codes que je viens de mentionner sont sans aucun doute intéressants et ils représentent un point de départ naturel pour
explorer la correction d'erreurs quantiques. Le problème, c'est qu'ils ne peuvent tolérer qu'un taux d'erreurs très faible
corriger une erreur sur un qubit parmi cinq, sept ou neuf, ce n'est pas mal, mais selon toute vraisemblance, du moins d'après ce que l'on suppose
on va avoir besoin de pouvoir tolérer beaucoup plus d'erreurs que ça pour rendre le calcul quantique à grande échelle une
réalité. Dans cette leçon, nous allons découvrir pour la première fois des constructions de codes correcteurs d'erreurs quantiques plus sophistiqués, notamment des codes qui peuvent
tolérer un taux d'erreurs bien plus élevé que ceux que nous avons vus jusqu'ici, et qui sont considérés comme des candidats prometteurs pour la correction d'erreurs quantiques pratique dans
les dispositifs physiques réels. Voici un bref aperçu de la leçon. Nous allons commencer par une classe de
codes correcteurs d'erreurs quantiques connus sous le nom de codes CSS, nommés d'après les chercheurs qui les ont découverts en premier : Robert Calderbank, Peter
Shor et Andrew Steane. La construction de codes CSS permet de prendre certaines paires de codes classiques
correcteurs d'erreurs et de les combiner pour former un code correcteur d'erreurs quantiques. Dans le cadre de cette discussion, nous allons
jeter un coup d'œil assez rapide aux codes linéaires classiques, et nous allons aussi parler de quelques-unes des propriétés de base des codes CSS
La deuxième partie de la leçon porte sur un code connu sous le nom de code Tore, qui est un exemple fondamental et vraiment
beau d'un code correcteur d'erreurs quantiques pouvant tolérer un taux d'erreurs relativement élevé. En fait,
le code Tore n'est pas un seul exemple de code correcteur d'erreurs quantiques, mais plutôt une famille infinie de codes, un pour
chaque entier positif à partir de deux. Dans la dernière partie de la leçon, nous allons brièvement discuter de quelques autres
familles de codes quantiques, notamment les surface codes, qui sont étroitement liés au code Tore, ainsi que
les codes couleur. Les gens étudient les codes correcteurs d'erreurs classiques depuis les années 1940
et c'est un sujet fascinant et riche. Les codes linéaires sont peut-être le type le plus simple de code correcteur d'erreurs classique
et je vais expliquer exactement ce que le mot linéaire signifie dans ce contexte dans un instant, mais une façon simple
de les exprimer, c'est que ce sont des codes stabilisateurs qui se trouvent être classiques, et on va voir tout à l'heure que
les codes CSS sont essentiellement des paires de codes linéaires classiques qui sont combinés pour créer une erreur quantique
code correcteur. Donc, pour les besoins de cette discussion, il va falloir comprendre quelques notions de base sur
les codes linéaires classiques. Tout d'abord, on va prendre Σ comme alphabet binaire pour toute cette
discussion. Et maintenant, quand on parle d'un code linéaire classique, on entend un ensemble C de chaînes binaires de longueur n pour un certain
entier positif n satisfaisant une seule propriété de base, à savoir que si u et v sont des chaînes binaires dans C, alors la chaîne
u XOR v est aussi dans C. Ici, u XOR v signifie le ou exclusif bit à bit de u et v, comme
on l'a vu à plusieurs reprises dans les leçons cinq et six dans la partie algorithmes quantiques de la série, et c'est ce que ça signifie pour un
code classique d'être linéaire. En substance, on considère les chaînes binaires de longueur n comme des vecteurs à n dimensions
dont les entrées sont toutes soit zéro, soit un, mais au lieu de l'addition vectorielle ordinaire sur les nombres réels ou complexes
on utilise l'addition modulo 2, qui est simplement le XOR. Donc, si on a
deux mots de code u et v, c'est-à-dire que u et v sont des chaînes binaires dans C, alors u plus v modulo 2, en d'autres termes u XOR
v, doit aussi être un mot de code dans C. Et soit dit en passant, cette implication doit être vraie même si u est égal à v, rien ne
l'exclut, et ça implique que tout code linéaire classique doit contenir la chaîne de zéros, parce que le
XOR bit à bit de n'importe quelle chaîne avec elle-même est la chaîne de zéros. Par exemple, le code de répétition à trois bits
est un code linéaire classique. En particulier, il y a deux choix possibles pour u et deux choix possibles
pour v, et c'est une affaire assez triviale de parcourir les paires possibles pour voir qu'on obtient toujours un mot de code quand on prend le
XOR bit à bit. Voici un autre exemple qu'on appelle le code de Hamming 7-4-3. C'est l'un des tout premiers codes correcteurs d'erreurs classiques
qui ait jamais été découvert, et il est composé de 16 chaînes binaires de longueur sept. Il y a une logique très simple
derrière la sélection de ces chaînes, mais je ne l'expliquerai pas dans cette vidéo. Je dois aussi mentionner qu'on voit parfois ces chaînes inversées, mais
pour l'instant, le point principal est que si on prend deux de ces chaînes et qu'on fait leur XOR, on obtiendra une autre chaîne dans le
code. Donc c'est un code linéaire, et la notation 7-4-3 entre crochets simples signifie quelque chose d'analogue aux doubles
crochets que j'ai mentionnés dans la leçon précédente pour les codes stabilisateurs, mais ici c'est pour les codes linéaires classiques
En particulier, les mots de code ont sept bits, il y a 16 mots de code, donc on peut encoder quatre bits grâce au code, et
il se trouve que c'est un code à distance trois, ce qui signifie qu'il faut retourner au moins trois bits d'un mot de code pour obtenir un
mot de code différent, et ça implique qu'il peut corriger jusqu'à une erreur de retournement de bit. Ce sont des exemples simples de
codes, mais même l'exemple du code de Hamming 7-4-3 semble un peu mystérieux quand on se contente de lister tous les mots de code, donc on a besoin de meilleurs moyens de
décrire les codes linéaires classiques, et il y a deux façons naturelles de le faire. Une façon de décrire les codes linéaires classiques est
de donner un ensemble minimal de mots de code qui génèrent le code, c'est-à-dire qu'en prenant tous les sous-ensembles possibles
de ces mots de code et en faisant leur XOR, on obtient le code entier, et c'est exprimé en termes mathématiques
ici à l'écran. Une autre façon de le voir, c'est qu'on considère ce code comme un sous-espace d'un espace vectoriel, et cet ensemble
de générateurs est une base pour ce sous-espace, en gardant à l'esprit que c'est un espace vectoriel où l'arithmétique est faite modulo 2. Si on a m générateurs, on va
se retrouver avec un code ayant deux à la puissance m éléments, chaque générateur double le nombre d'éléments dans le code, et
c'est cohérent avec le fait que les codes linéaires classiques sur l'alphabet binaire incluent toujours un nombre de chaînes qui est une puissance de
deux. La deuxième façon naturelle de décrire un code linéaire classique est par les contrôles de parité. Plus précisément, c'est une liste minimale
de chaînes binaires ayant la même longueur que les chaînes du code, telle que les chaînes du code sont précisément celles dont le produit binaire
avec chacune de ces chaînes de contrôle de parité est zéro, où le produit binaire est simplement le produit scalaire ordinaire
WEBVTT
modulo 2, et c'est encore quelque chose qu'on a rencontré dans la leçon cinq dans le contexte des algorithmes de requête
Et la raison pour laquelle on les appelle chaînes de contrôle de parité, c'est qu'une chaîne donnée u a un produit binaire égal à
zéro avec v si et seulement si les bits de u correspondant aux uns dans v ont une parité
paire. Quand on décrit un code linéaire classique de cette façon, par une liste minimale de chaînes de contrôle de parité, chaque
chaîne de contrôle de parité divise le nombre de chaînes dans le code par deux. Donc pour un seul code décrit de ces deux façons différentes, on aura toujours m + r égal à
n. Une chose importante à noter ici est que le produit binaire n'est pas un produit scalaire au sens formel, et en
particulier, quand deux chaînes ont un produit binaire égal à zéro, ça ne signifie pas qu'elles sont orthogonales de la façon dont on pense habituellement à
l'orthogonalité. Par exemple, le produit binaire de la chaîne un un avec elle-même est zéro, donc il est possible qu'
une de ces chaînes de contrôle de parité soit elle-même dans le code, donc c'est juste quelque chose à garder à
l'esprit. Par exemple, comme on le sait déjà, le code de répétition à 3 bits est un code linéaire, donc il peut être décrit de ces deux
façons. En particulier, il n'y a qu'un seul choix pour un générateur qui fonctionne, et c'est 111, et on peut alternativement décrire
le code avec ces deux chaînes de contrôle de parité, qui devraient nous sembler familières d'après nos discussions précédentes sur ce
code. Et pour le code de Hamming 7-4-3, on peut utiliser ces générateurs et ces contrôles de
parité. Ici, toutes nos chaînes de contrôle de parité se trouvent elles-mêmes être dans le code
Un dernier commentaire sur les codes linéaires classiques juste pour les relier au formalisme des stabilisateurs : ces chaînes de contrôle de parité
sont équivalentes aux générateurs de stabilisateurs où on n'a que des matrices de Pauli Z et identité. Par exemple, les chaînes de contrôle de parité
110 et 011 pour le code de répétition à 3 bits correspondent précisément aux générateurs de stabilisateurs ZZ identité
et identité ZZ, et c'est cohérent avec notre discussion des observables de ce type dans la leçon précédente
Ensuite, on va discuter des codes CSS, qui sont des codes stabilisateurs qu'on peut obtenir en combinant certaines
paires de codes linéaires classiques ayant le même nombre de bits dans leurs encodages. Ça ne fonctionne pas pour n'importe quelles deux
codes linéaires classiques, les deux codes doivent avoir une certaine relation comme on va le voir dans un instant, mais néanmoins cette
construction ouvre beaucoup de possibilités pour les codes correcteurs d'erreurs quantiques, basées en partie sur ce qu'on a appris de plus de 75 ans de
théorie du codage classique. J'ai déjà mentionné que dans le formalisme des stabilisateurs, les générateurs de stabilisateurs
contenant uniquement des matrices de Pauli Z et identité sont équivalents aux contrôles de parité. Par exemple, dans le code de répétition à trois bits
on peut utiliser les chaînes de contrôle de parité 1 1 0 et 011 qui imposent que les deux bits les plus à gauche sont
égaux et les deux bits les plus à droite sont égaux pour chaque chaîne dans le code, et ces deux chaînes de contrôle de parité correspondent précisément aux générateurs de stabilisateurs
ZZ identité et identité ZZ. Pour le code de Hamming 7-4-3, on peut utiliser
ces chaînes de contrôle de parité et elles correspondent à ces générateurs de stabilisateurs où on remplace simplement chaque un par un Z et chaque zéro par l'identité
Tu reconnaîtras peut-être ces générateurs de stabilisateurs, parce que ce sont trois des six générateurs de stabilisateurs du code de Steane à 7 qubit. C'est
certainement pas une coïncidence, et on va voir exactement ce qui se passe ici dans un instant. On va donner le nom Z
stabilisateurs aux générateurs de stabilisateurs comme ceux-ci, c'est-à-dire qu'ils n'ont que des facteurs tensoriels Pauli Z et identité
Donc X et Y n'apparaissent jamais dans un générateur de stabilisateur Z. On peut aussi considérer
des générateurs de stabilisateurs où seules des matrices de Pauli X et identité apparaissent, et on peut penser à ces générateurs de stabilisateurs comme étant complètement analogues
aux générateurs de stabilisateurs Z, sauf qu'ils décrivent essentiellement des contrôles de parité dans la base plus-moins plutôt que la
base standard. Par exemple, revenons au code de Hamming 7-4-3, on peut penser aux
trois générateurs de stabilisateurs restants du code de Steane à 7 qubit, qui suivent exactement le même schéma que pour les générateurs de stabilisateurs Z pour ce
code, mais cette fois on substitue X à un plutôt que Z, et ce qu'on obtient avec ces trois seuls générateurs de stabilisateurs
est un code qui inclut les 16 états montrés ici, qu'on obtient en appliquant des Hadamard gates aux états de la base standard
correspondant aux chaînes dans le code de Hamming 7-4-3, et bien sûr notre espace de code inclut aussi
des combinaisons linéaires de ces états. Naturellement, les générateurs de stabilisateurs de cette forme sont appelés générateurs de stabilisateurs X
donc aucun y ou z n'est autorisé cette fois, et maintenant on peut définir les codes CSS en
termes simples : les codes CSS sont des codes stabilisateurs qui peuvent être exprimés en utilisant seulement des
générateurs de stabilisateurs Z et des générateurs de stabilisateurs X. Donc pas de Y autorisé, et pas de X et Z apparaissant dans le même générateur de stabilisateur
Et pour être sûr que c'est clair, on doit garder à l'esprit qu'il y a une liberté dans la façon dont on choisit les générateurs de stabilisateurs pour les codes stabilisateurs
et ce que dit cette définition, c'est qu'un code CSS est un code pour lequel il est possible de choisir uniquement des générateurs de stabilisateurs Z et X
mais en général on pourrait choisir des générateurs de stabilisateurs différents qui pourraient ne pas être des générateurs de stabilisateurs Z ou X si on le voulait
Voici à peu près l'exemple non trivial le plus simple d'un code CSS qu'on peut avoir, où il y a à la fois un stabilisateur Z
et un générateur de stabilisateur X, et vérifier ça ne demande pas plus qu'un coup d'œil étant donné qu'on sait déjà de
la leçon précédente que c'est un code stabilisateur valide. L'espace de code est de dimension un, c'est l'espace engendré par un
ebit plus, et on peut observer que nos deux générateurs de stabilisateurs agissent trivialement sur ce vecteur en considérant
les deux expressions d'un ebit montrées à l'écran ainsi que l'interprétation des générateurs de stabilisateurs comme contrôles de parité dans les bases 0-1
et plus-moins. Le code de Steane à 7 qubit est un autre exemple de code CSS parce que pour ce
choix de générateurs on n'a que des générateurs de stabilisateurs Z et X, et là encore on sait déjà que c'est un
code stabilisateur valide. Et le code de Shor à N=9 qubit est un autre exemple. Cette fois on a six
générateurs de stabilisateurs Z et seulement deux générateurs de stabilisateurs X, et c'est bien, pas besoin d'équilibre ni de
symétrie entre les deux types. Il est cependant essentiel qu'on ait réellement un code stabilisateur valide, et ça signifie
que chacun des générateurs de stabilisateurs Z doit commuter avec chacun des générateurs de stabilisateurs X, donc on ne peut pas
simplement choisir les deux types de générateurs indépendamment, et je dirai un peu plus à ce sujet plus tard dans la leçon. Ensuite, on va discuter
de la détection et correction d'erreurs pour les codes CSS, et ce qu'on va trouver, c'est que la propriété qu'on a observée pour le code de Shor à 9 qubit
qu'on peut détecter et corriger les erreurs X et les erreurs Z indépendamment, s'applique en général pour les codes CSS
Pour l'expliquer davantage, considérons un code CSS comme le code de Steane à 7 qubit, mais ça pourrait être un code CSS différent si
WEBVTT
tu préfères. L'idée de base est que les générateurs de stabilisateurs Z détectent les erreurs X
mais sont complètement aveugles aux erreurs Z, parce que les générateurs de stabilisateurs Z commutent toujours avec les
erreurs Z. De plus, les générateurs de stabilisateurs Z commutent aussi avec les Z gates qu'on pourrait choisir d'appliquer comme
corrections pour les erreurs Z. De même, les générateurs de stabilisateurs X détectent les erreurs Z, mais sont complètement
aveugles aux erreurs X et aux corrections. Donc, on peut en essence considérer les générateurs de stabilisateurs Z comme représentant un
code linéaire classique qui protège contre les retournements de bits, ou en d'autres termes les erreurs X, tandis que les générateurs de stabilisateurs X
représentent un code linéaire classique dans la base plus-moins qui protège complètement indépendamment contre les retournements
entre les états plus et moins, ou en d'autres termes les erreurs de retournement de phase, ou erreurs Z. Donc maintenant il est assez clair ce qui se passe
avec le code de Steane : c'est simplement un code de Hamming 7-4-3 pour les erreurs de retournement de bits et un code de Hamming 7-4-3 pour les erreurs de retournement de phase
Une fois encore, le fait que les générateurs de stabilisateurs Z et les générateurs de stabilisateurs X commutent est requis.
Ce ne serait pas un code stabilisateur valide s'ils ne commutaient pas, et on pourrait dire que c'est une heureuse coïncidence que le code de Hamming 7-4-3
fonctionne ainsi, mais il y a beaucoup d'autres choix qu'on peut faire pour des paires de codes linéaires classiques qui nous donneront un code stabilisateur valide
quand ils sont combinés de cette façon. Maintenant, pour revenir aux codes CSS en général, supposons que les générateurs de stabilisateurs Z
permettent la correction de jusqu'à disons j erreurs X, et les générateurs de stabilisateurs X permettent la correction
de jusqu'à k erreurs Z. Donc dans le cas du code de Steane, j et k valent tous deux un parce que
le code de Hamming 7-4-3 peut corriger un retournement de bit, mais en général ces nombres j et k pourraient être différents
Il s'ensuit alors par la discrétisation des erreurs que le code CSS peut corriger n'importe quelle erreur sur un nombre de qubit jusqu'à
le minimum de j et k. C'est parce que quand on mesure le syndrome, une erreur arbitraire sur un certain
nombre de qubit s'effondre de façon probabiliste en une combinaison d'erreurs X, d'erreurs Z, ou les deux, et alors
les erreurs X et les erreurs Z peuvent être détectées et corrigées indépendamment. Donc tant qu'on a deux
codes linéaires classiques qui s'entendent bien dans le sens où ils nous donnent des générateurs de stabilisateurs X et Z qui commutent, le
code CSS qu'on obtient en les combinant hérite essentiellement des propriétés de correction d'erreurs des deux codes dans le sens que je viens de
décrire. Remarque qu'il y a un coût à payer cependant, à savoir qu'on ne peut pas encoder autant de qubit qu'on pouvait encoder de bits
avec les deux codes classiques, parce que le nombre total de générateurs de stabilisateurs pour le code CSS est la somme des
nombres de contrôles de parité pour les deux codes classiques, et chaque générateur de stabilisateurs réduit la dimension de l'espace de code de
moitié. Par exemple, le code de Hamming 7-4-3 permet l'encodage de quatre bits classiques parce qu'on a juste
trois contrôles de parité pour ce code, alors que le code de Steane à 7 qubit n'encode qu'un qubit parce qu'il a six
générateurs de stabilisateurs. La dernière chose que j'expliquerai sur les codes CSS en général dans cette leçon concerne les espaces de codes CSS
et à quoi ils ressemblent, et ça nous donnera aussi l'occasion d'examiner un peu plus en détail la relation qui doit exister entre
deux codes linéaires classiques pour qu'ils soient compatibles dans le sens où on peut les combiner pour former un code CSS
Considère un code CSS arbitraire sur n qubit, et soit Z1 à Zs les chaînes de parité à n bits
correspondant aux générateurs de stabilisateurs Z. Ça signifie que le code linéaire classique
décrit par les générateurs de stabilisateurs Z, qu'on appellera CZ juste pour nous aider à nous rappeler que c'est
le code correspondant aux générateurs de stabilisateurs Z, prend la forme montrée ici à l'écran. En mots, le code contient chaque
chaîne u dont le produit binaire avec chacune des chaînes de contrôle de parité est zéro. Si on le voulait, on pourrait aussi
considérer un code différent dérivé de ces mêmes chaînes, qu'on appellera DZ, et l'idée ici est qu'on pense à
ces chaînes Z1 à Zs non pas comme des chaînes de contrôle de parité mais plutôt comme des générateurs
À ce stade, il n'est pas clair pourquoi on voudrait penser à ce code, mais on peut le faire et ça s'avérera pertinent pour cette
discussion. Ce code est appelé le code Dual de CZ et est communément noté CZ perp signifiant CZ avec le symbole perpendiculaire
en exposant, mais on va l'appeler DZ et ce sera facile à retenir parce que D est l'abréviation de
Dual. On peut aussi faire quelque chose de similaire avec les générateurs de stabilisateurs X. Cette fois CX est le code linéaire classique
dont les chaînes de contrôle de parité correspondent aux générateurs de stabilisateurs X, et DX est le code Dual de ce code. En passant,
on peut maintenant décrire les conditions qui doivent être satisfaites pour que CZ et CX soient compatibles dans le sens où on peut
les apparier comme un code CSS. En termes de ces codes eux-mêmes, il faut spécifiquement que
DZ soit contenu dans CX, ou de façon équivalente que DX soit contenu dans CZ. Et il est maintenant
possible de décrire l'espace de code du code CSS dérivé de ces deux codes, et une façon de le décrire est que
c'est l'espace engendré par tous les vecteurs qui ont la forme montrée à l'écran. En mots, ils ressemblent à des superpositions uniformes
sur les chaînes dans le code Dual DX du code correspondant aux générateurs de stabilisateurs X, décalées
par ou XOR par des chaînes dans le code CZ correspondant aux générateurs de stabilisateurs Z, et on va voir à quoi ça ressemble
dans le cas spécifique du code de Steane dans un instant. Ça a du sens parce que les états dans l'espace de code doivent être
des vecteurs propres de valeur +1 de tous les générateurs de stabilisateurs, et en particulier multiplier par l'un des générateurs de stabilisateurs X
est équivalent à XOR par la chaîne X correspondante. C'est pourquoi ces superpositions uniformes
sur DX décalées par des chaînes différentes apparaissent ainsi. Des choix différents pour le décalage
représenté par la chaîne Y dans cette expression peuvent nous donner le même vecteur, donc ces états ne sont pas tous distincts, mais collectivement ils engendrent
l'espace de code entier. Il y a une symétrie ici entre les générateurs de stabilisateurs X et Z et
les codes auxquels ils correspondent, et donc on peut utiliser cette symétrie pour décrire les vecteurs dans l'espace de code de façon analogue en échangeant X et Z, mais
on doit aussi échanger les bases standard pour les bases plus-moins, c'est pourquoi les Hadamard opérations apparaissent dans cette
expression. Maintenant pour l'exemple qui avait été promis, c'est-à-dire le code de Steane, on obtient ces deux encodages possibles
des états de base standard zéro et un. En particulier, on peut encoder l'état zéro comme une superposition uniforme
sur les huit chaînes dans le code Dual du code de Hamming 7-4-3, qui s'avère être la moitié des chaînes dans le code de Hamming 7-4-3, et on
peut encoder l'état un de façon similaire, sauf que toutes les chaînes sont XOR par la chaîne de tous-uns dans ce cas
WEBVTT
parce que cette chaîne se trouve être dans le code de Hamming 7-4-3 mais pas dans son dual. Un dernier commentaire ici est qu'on ne se soucie souvent
pas vraiment de savoir à quoi ressemblent les vecteurs dans nos espaces de codes, parce qu'on n'a généralement pas besoin de le savoir pour utiliser les
codes. Donc si cette explication n'était pas claire, c'est vraiment pas quelque chose qui devrait t'inquiéter trop, mais il est certainement
naturel de se demander à quoi ressemblent les vecteurs dans les espaces de codes des codes CSS, et cette description fournit une réponse à cette
question. Ensuite, on va discuter d'un code CSS spécifique connu sous le nom de code Tore, qui est un exemple de ce qu'on appelle un
code correcteur d'erreurs quantiques topologique. Ce code a été découvert par Alexei Kitaev en
1997. En fait, le code Tore n'est pas un seul code mais plutôt une famille de codes, un pour chaque entier positif d'au
moins deux. Ces codes possèdent quelques propriétés clés. La première propriété clé est
que tous les générateurs de stabilisateurs ont un faible poids en tant qu'opérations de Pauli. En particulier, ils vont tous avoir
un poids de quatre, et c'est bien parce que ça signifie que chacune des mesures de générateurs de stabilisateurs n'a pas besoin d'impliquer
trop de qubit. Parfois, les gens parlent de codes ldpc quantiques, ou codes quantiques à faible densité de contrôle de parité
et c'est ce que ce terme signifie, où dans ce cas faible signifie quatre. Donc le code Tore est un exemple de
code ldpc quantique. Le code Tore a aussi ce qu'on appelle la localité géométrique, ce qui signifie que non seulement
les générateurs de stabilisateurs ont un faible poids, mais il est aussi possible d'arranger les qubit spatialement de sorte que
chacune des mesures de générateurs de stabilisateurs n'implique que des qubit qui sont proches les uns des autres, ce qui rend ces mesures plus faciles à implémenter en
principe. Et enfin, ces codes ont une grande distance, donc ils peuvent tolérer un taux d'erreurs relativement élevé
Voici comment ces codes fonctionnent. D'abord, soit L un entier positif
d'au moins deux et considère un réseau L par L avec des frontières dites périodiques
Par exemple, voici un réseau L par L pour L=8 et remarque que les lignes
à droite et en bas sont des lignes pointillées, et l'idée ici est qu'on veut considérer la ligne pointillée à droite comme étant la même ligne que
la ligne à gauche, et de même, la ligne pointillée en bas est la même ligne que celle du
haut. Donc si on voulait vraiment réaliser ce type de configuration physiquement, on aurait besoin de trois
dimensions. En particulier, on pourrait former un cylindre en faisant d'abord correspondre les côtés gauche et droit, puis plier le
cylindre de sorte que les cercles aux extrémités, qui étaient autrefois les bords supérieur et inférieur du réseau, se rejoignent, ou on
pourrait faire correspondre le haut et le bas d'abord, puis les côtés. Les deux façons fonctionnent et peu importe comment tu le fais pour les besoins de cette
discussion. Ce qu'on obtient est un Tore, en d'autres termes un beignet, bien que le penser comme la chambre à air d'un pneu est
peut-être une meilleure image à avoir en tête, parce que ce n'est pas un objet solide. Le réseau est effectivement devenu juste la surface d'un
Tore, et c'est de là que vient le nom de code Tore. La façon dont tu peux te déplacer sur
un Tore comme celui-ci, en supposant que tu peux te déplacer entre des points adjacents sur le réseau, sera probablement familière aux personnes qui ont joué à des jeux vidéo à l'ancienne
où si tu sors par le bord supérieur de l'écran tu réapparais en bas, et de même pour les bords gauche et droit de l'
écran. Et pour l'essentiel, c'est ainsi que je vais décrire ce réseau, plutôt que de parler spécifiquement d'un
Tore dans un espace tridimensionnel. Ensuite, on imagine que des qubit sont
placés sur les arêtes du réseau, comme illustré ici à l'écran, où les qubit sont indiqués par des cercles bleus pleins
Remarque que les qubit placés sur les lignes pointillées ne sont pas pleins, et c'est parce qu'on les a déjà représentés
soit par ceux du haut, soit par ceux du côté gauche, en gardant à l'esprit que les lignes du haut et de gauche sont exactement les mêmes lignes que celles
indiquées par les lignes pointillées en bas et à droite. Et donc si on compte tous ces qubit, on obtient 2 × L² qubit, et une
façon de le voir est d'observer qu'on obtient L² qubit sur les arêtes horizontales et L² qubit sur les arêtes verticales
Voilà donc la disposition de nos qubit, et pour décrire le code Tore lui-même, on n'a qu'à décrire les générateurs de stabilisateurs
et il y en a deux types. D'abord, on a les générateurs de stabilisateurs Z
et ils correspondent aux tuiles ou aux plaques dans la figure. Et deuxièmement, on a les générateurs de stabilisateurs X
et ils correspondent aux sommets dans la figure. Donc par exemple, voici un
générateur de stabilisateur, ce qui signifie qu'on tensorise ensemble une opération Pauli Z pour chacun des qubit touchant cette tuile, ainsi que des matrices identité
sur tous les autres qubit, et ça nous donne une opération de Pauli de poids 4. Et voici un exemple d'un
générateur de stabilisateur X, où on a des matrices Pauli X agissant sur les quatre qubit incidents à ce sommet, ainsi que des
matrices identité sur tous les autres qubit. Donc là encore, c'est une opération de Pauli de poids 4. Il est important que pour les deux
types de générateurs de stabilisateurs on inclue ceux qui se replient aux frontières périodiques, et voici un exemple d'un générateur de stabilisateur X
qui fait ça. Maintenant, pour obtenir un code stabilisateur valide, on a besoin que les générateurs de stabilisateurs
commutent. Les générateurs de stabilisateurs Z commutent tous entre eux parce que Z commute avec lui-même et l'identité
commute avec tout, et de même pour les générateurs de stabilisateurs X. Il est aussi clair qu'un générateur de stabilisateur Z et un
générateur de stabilisateur X commutent quand ils agissent de façon non triviale sur des ensembles disjoints de qubit, comme pour les deux générateurs montrés
ici. La possibilité restante est qu'un générateur de stabilisateur Z et un générateur de stabilisateur X se chevauchent, et
chaque fois que ça arrive, c'est toujours sur deux qubit sur lesquels ils se chevauchent, et donc les générateurs de stabilisateurs commutent parce que ZZ
et XX commutent. Maintenant, ce n'est pas un ensemble minimal de générateurs de stabilisateurs. En particulier, si on multiplie
tous les générateurs de stabilisateurs Z ensemble, on obtient l'identité parce que chaque qubit est multiplié par Z deux fois
une fois pour chacune des tuiles qui touche le qubit. Ça signifie que multiplier tous les générateurs de stabilisateurs Z ensemble
sauf un nous donne ce dernier, donc ils ne sont pas indépendants, mais si on en retire un quelconque, on obtiendra
un ensemble indépendant, et c'est pareil pour les générateurs de stabilisateurs X. Donc on peut en retirer un de chaque type
et peu importe lesquels on retire, et ça laisse L²-1 générateurs de stabilisateurs de chaque type. Pour être
clair là-dessus, et c'est quelque chose que j'ai évoqué dans la leçon précédente, on se soucie réellement de tous ces générateurs de stabilisateurs, et dans un sens strictement
opérationnel, on ne va pas vraiment en choisir un de chaque type à ignorer, mais pour l'analyse du code, on peut
imaginer qu'un générateur de stabilisateurs de chaque type a été retiré de façon à obtenir un ensemble générateur minimal, en gardant à l'esprit
WEBVTT
qu'on pourrait toujours déduire les résultats de ces générateurs retirés, en les considérant comme des observables, à partir des résultats de tous les autres générateurs de stabilisateurs
du même type. Donc le nombre de qubit que ce code encode est égal au nombre total de
qubit, qui est 2×L², moins le nombre total de générateurs de stabilisateurs dans un ensemble générateur minimal, qui est 2×L²-
1, et ça signifie qu'on peut encoder 2 qubit. Je n'ai pas argumenté soit dit en passant que l'espace de code est non trivial, mais il l'est bien
effectivement, et je te laisse te convaincre qu'il n'y a aucun moyen de multiplier des générateurs de stabilisateurs de façon à obtenir
−1 fois l'identité. Donc voilà le code Tore lui-même, et à ce stade il n'est peut-être pas du tout
clair pourquoi ce code devrait être bon pour la correction d'erreurs quantiques. Il nous reste à l'analyser, et ce qu'on va trouver, c'est que c'est en fait un
code correcteur d'erreurs quantiques assez remarquable. Pour comprendre comment le code Tore fonctionne comme un code correcteur d'erreurs quantiques,
on va commencer par considérer différentes erreurs et les syndromes qu'elles génèrent. La première chose à noter est que
le code Tore est un code CSS parce que tous nos générateurs de stabilisateurs sont soit des générateurs de stabilisateurs Z soit des générateurs de stabilisateurs X
et ce que ça signifie, c'est que les erreurs X et les erreurs Z peuvent être détectées et éventuellement corrigées
séparément. Et en fait, il y a une symétrie simple entre les générateurs de stabilisateurs Z et X qui nous permet d'analyser les erreurs X
et les erreurs Z essentiellement de la même façon. Donc je vais me concentrer sur les erreurs X, qui sont potentiellement détectées par les
générateurs de stabilisateurs Z, et tu peux tout traduire aux erreurs Z, qui sont potentiellement détectées par les générateurs de stabilisateurs X, en utilisant exactement les
mêmes idées. Voici une figure illustrant nos deux qubit carrés sur les arêtes d'un réseau L
par L avec des frontières périodiques, et on peut imaginer que c'est disposé sur la surface d'un
Tore. En ce moment, tous les qubit sont bleus, indiquant que ce sont des qubit qui n'ont pas été affectés par
des erreurs. Donc tu devrais imaginer qu'à ce stade, l'état de ces qubit est dans l'espace de code pour ce
code. Comme je l'ai mentionné, notre attention va se porter sur les erreurs X, et dans un instant on va utiliser des cercles magenta pour indiquer des qubit qui
ont été affectés par des erreurs X. Les erreurs X sont détectées par les générateurs de stabilisateurs Z, qui correspondent
aux tuiles dans la figure. Donc ce qu'on peut faire, c'est laisser les tuiles blanches indiquer des résultats de mesure à +1, ou en d'autres termes
les entrées dans le syndrome correspondant à ce générateur, tandis que les tuiles grises vont indiquer des résultats de mesure à
-1. Tu peux penser à un résultat à +1, ou en d'autres termes une tuile blanche, comme indiquant que le générateur de stabilisateurs
correspondant est content, tout semble bien pour ce générateur. Tandis qu'un résultat à -1 ou une tuile grise
indique que le générateur de stabilisateurs correspondant est mécontent parce qu'évidemment une erreur a dû se produire pour causer ce
résultat. Donc pour l'instant, tous nos générateurs de stabilisateurs sont contents parce qu'aucune erreur n'est survenue. Maintenant si on pense
à un générateur de stabilisateurs Z, tout ce qu'il fait c'est mesurer la parité des 4 qubit qui touchent la tuile par rapport
à la base standard. Donc un résultat à +1 n'indique pas qu'aucune erreur X ne s'est produite sur ces quatre
qubit, mais plutôt qu'un nombre pair d'erreurs X se sont produites, tandis qu'un résultat à -1 indique
qu'un nombre impair d'erreurs X se sont produites. Donc maintenant, introduisons une erreur X et voyons ce qui
arrive. Les deux générateurs de stabilisateurs Z correspondant aux tuiles qui touchent ce qubit sont maintenant mécontents parce que cette
erreur X anti-commute avec ces deux générateurs, ou de façon équivalente en termes de base standard, on est maintenant dans
un état où ces deux ensembles de quatre qubit correspondant aux deux tuiles ont une parité impaire. Voilà donc l'effet d'une seule
erreur X. Donc si on devait mesurer ce syndrome et qu'on savait ou supposait qu'une seule erreur X s'était produite, on serait
en mesure de déduire facilement quel qubit avait été retourné et on pourrait simplement le remettre à l'endroit avec un X gate. Maintenant, voyons ce qui arrive
quand on introduit des erreurs X supplémentaires, et en particulier voyons ce qui arrive quand une deuxième erreur X se produit sur un autre
qubit touchant l'une des tuiles grises, disons la tuile grise du haut
comme ça. Cette tuile est maintenant contente parce que deux erreurs X se sont produites sur les qubit touchant cette tuile, et deux est pair. Donc
ces deux erreurs X ensemble commutent avec le générateur de stabilisateurs pour cette tuile. Une autre façon de dire ça est que
cette deuxième erreur X a fait passer tous les états de la base standard de ces quatre qubit d'une parité impaire à une parité paire
La tuile à gauche de cette nouvelle erreur X, en revanche, est maintenant mécontente
On peut continuer ce processus d'ajout de nouvelles erreurs X, et tant qu'on forme une chaîne d'erreurs X adjacentes où adjacent signifie que les qubit touchent la
même tuile, on va effectivement pousser ce résultat de mesure à -1 autour, et ce qu'on trouve, c'est qu'on a toujours des
résultats de mesure de syndrome à -1 aux extrémités des chaînes d'erreurs adjacentes. Donc on peut toujours détecter des chaînes
d'erreurs X adjacentes tant qu'elles ont des extrémités. Il pourrait y avoir plusieurs chaînes soit dit en passant, mais on reviendra
à cette possibilité plus tard. Il est possible cependant qu'on ait une chaîne d'erreurs X adjacentes qui
n'a pas d'extrémités, c'est-à-dire que notre chaîne d'erreurs pourrait former une boucle fermée. Donc ajoutons quelques erreurs supplémentaires de sorte
qu'elles forment une boucle fermée comme ça par exemple. On a maintenant un nombre pair d'erreurs X
sur chaque tuile, donc chaque générateur de stabilisateurs est maintenant content, et ce qu'on a trouvé, c'est que les boucles fermées
d'erreurs X adjacentes ne sont pas détectées par ce code parce qu'on obtient le syndrome tout à +1 dans ce
cas. Ça pourrait sembler un peu décevant. En fait, il suffit de quatre erreurs X adjacentes pour former une boucle fermée
et on espère quelque chose de mieux qu'un code à distance 4. Cependant, certaines boucles fermées
d'erreurs X adjacentes sont elles-mêmes dans le stabilisateur. Rappelle-toi qu'on a un générateur de stabilisateurs X pour chaque sommet dans
le réseau, et si on multiplie des générateurs de stabilisateurs X adjacents, on peut former des boucles fermées d'opérations X
comme on en a justement ici pour la boucle fermée qu'on vient de construire il y a quelques instants. Donc certaines boucles fermées d'erreurs X
comme celle montrée ici ne sont pas du tout des erreurs parce qu'elles sont dans le stabilisateur, elles ne font donc rien du tout à l'espace de code. Il y a cependant
certaines boucles fermées d'erreurs X qui ne sont pas dans le stabilisateur et qui représentent donc des erreurs non triviales qui passent
inaperçues par le code. Et il y a une façon assez simple de caractériser les différents types de
boucles. Les boucles qui croisent chaque ligne dans le réseau, c'est-à-dire chaque ligne verticale de haut en bas et chaque ligne horizontale
de gauche à droite, un nombre pair de fois, sont toujours des produits de générateurs de stabilisateurs X. Ça inclut l'exemple
montré à l'écran ainsi que des boucles qui peuvent être bien plus compliquées, y compris la possibilité qu'elles croisent les frontières périodiques, mais
WEBVTT
néanmoins, en multipliant ces boucles fermées d'erreurs X par des générateurs de stabilisateurs X, elles peuvent être effectivement réduites à
rien. Et c'est certainement vrai soit dit en passant qu'on ne peut obtenir des boucles comme ça qu'en multipliant des générateurs de stabilisateurs X ensemble, parce que chaque générateur de stabilisateurs X
met un nombre pair d'opérations X sur chaque ligne horizontale et sur chaque ligne verticale
L'autre type de boucle fermée qu'on peut avoir est une boucle qui croise au moins une ligne un nombre impair de fois, comme
celle montrée ici, qui croise chaque ligne horizontale exactement une fois. Et voici un autre exemple qui croise
chaque ligne verticale exactement une fois. Donc ce sont des exemples d'erreurs non triviales qui passent inaperçues par le code, mais le point
clé ici est que la seule façon de former une boucle fermée comme celle-ci est de faire le tour du Tore, soit autour du trou dans le
milieu du Tore, soit à travers le trou, ou ça pourrait être les deux. C'est une propriété topologique
concernant les tores, c'est tout à propos des trous essentiellement, et c'est pourquoi on appelle ça un code correcteur d'erreurs quantiques topologique
En termes de cette visualisation d'un réseau bidimensionnel avec des frontières périodiques, une chaîne dans cette catégorie doit
faire une boucle autour d'une ou des deux frontières périodiques d'une façon qui rend impossible de contracter cette boucle à un
point en la multipliant par des générateurs de stabilisateurs X. Une telle chaîne pourrait être plus
compliquée que celle illustrée ici, mais c'est la plus courte qu'une telle boucle puisse être, parce qu'elle doit d'une façon ou d'une autre faire le tour
d'une ou des deux frontières périodiques. Et ce que ça implique, c'est que le poids minimal d'une erreur non triviale
non détectable est L. Toute boucle fermée avec moins d'erreurs que ça doit tomber dans la première catégorie et est donc
dans le stabilisateur. Et les chaînes d'erreurs qui ne forment pas de boucles fermées sont détectées par le code. Voilà, c'est pour ça que ce code
fonctionne, et ce qu'on obtient, c'est un code stabilisateur 2L²-2-L. On utilise 2L²
qubit pour encoder 2 qubit et le code a une distance L. Ensuite, je vais dire juste un peu
sur la correction d'erreurs avec le code Tore, sans trop entrer dans les détails. Si on mesure le syndrome et
qu'on voit autre chose que le syndrome tout à +1, où je parle ici seulement des générateurs de stabilisateurs Z,
alors les résultats à -1 nous indiquent les extrémités d'une ou plusieurs chaînes d'erreurs X adjacentes, et on peut tenter de corriger
ces erreurs en appariant les résultats à -1 et en formant une chaîne de corrections X entre eux. Et comme
on fait ça, il est logique de choisir les plus courts chemins pour nos corrections. Par exemple, si on mesure un
syndrome comme celui montré ici, alors on pourrait choisir ce chemin entre les tuiles mécontentes et appliquer des
X gates comme corrections le long de ce chemin. Bien sûr, la chaîne d'erreurs réelle causant le syndrome pourrait avoir
été différente, comme celle montrée ici, mais c'est ok tant que les erreurs et les corrections ensemble
tombent dans le stabilisateur. Il pourrait aussi arriver que nos corrections complètent une boucle autour du
Tore, ce qui est mauvais parce qu'en faisant ça on a causé une erreur logique. Donc cette stratégie de corriger
sur les plus courts chemins corrige les erreurs de faible poids, mais elle pourrait ne pas fonctionner pour les erreurs de poids plus élevé. Mais bien sûr on ne peut pas
espérer mieux que ça de n'importe quel code correcteur d'erreurs quantiques. Plus vraisemblablement peut-être, selon le modèle de bruit, c'est qu'on
observe un tas de -1 dans le syndrome, et dans ce cas on peut utiliser des algorithmes classiques efficaces pour nous aider
à les apparier et trouver une erreur de poids minimal représentant le syndrome. Comme je l'ai mentionné dans la leçon précédente,
ça ne corrige pas toujours l'explication la plus probable du syndrome, mais ça fonctionne assez bien en général
et ça réussit toujours à corriger les erreurs de poids strictement inférieur à la moitié de la distance L. Et je dois aussi
mentionner qu'il y a d'autres stratégies mieux adaptées à différents modèles d'erreurs. Ça fait plus de 25 ans depuis la
découverte du code Tore et pendant ce temps il y a eu pas mal de travail sur les codes correcteurs d'erreurs quantiques, notamment
d'autres codes correcteurs d'erreurs quantiques topologiques inspirés du code Tore, ainsi que des codes basés sur des
idées différentes. Je ne peux certainement pas te donner une liste exhaustive de toutes les différentes constructions de codes connues, mais je vais gratter la surface
juste un peu et mentionner brièvement quelques exemples bien connus. D'abord, il s'avère que ce n'est pas
vraiment essentiel que le code Tore ait des frontières périodiques, c'est-à-dire qu'il est possible de découper juste une portion du code Tore et
de l'aplatir sur une surface bidimensionnelle plutôt que sur un Tore, et ce qu'on obtient en faisant ça s'appelle un surface
code. Par exemple, si on coupe les bords d'un réseau selon le motif montré ici avec des bords dits rugueux en
haut et en bas et des bords lisses sur les côtés, et qu'on inclut en conséquence des cas limites pour les générateurs de stabilisateurs,
on obtient un code qui peut encoder juste un qubit cette fois, mais le code hérite néanmoins des
caractéristiques les plus importantes du code Tore. En particulier, les erreurs non triviales non détectables pour ce code doivent
correspondre à des chaînes d'erreurs qui s'étendent soit du bord gauche au bord droit, soit du haut vers le bas,
selon qu'il s'agit de chaînes d'erreurs X ou Z respectivement. Il est aussi possible de couper
les bords en diagonale pour obtenir ce qu'on appelle parfois des surface codes tournés, et faire ça peut être utile pour rendre
les codes plus économiques en termes de nombre de qubit utilisés. Par exemple, si on prend ce surface
code et qu'on supprime quelques qubit, laissant un carré orienté en diagonale, on obtient un autre surface
code, tant qu'on spécifie les générateurs de stabilisateurs sur la frontière de la bonne façon. Des diagrammes comme celui-ci sont
utiles pour clarifier comment les générateurs de stabilisateurs sont définis, où les tuiles noires y compris celles arrondies sur les bords indiquent les générateurs de stabilisateurs X
et les blanches indiquent les générateurs de stabilisateurs Z. Celles sur la frontière soit dit en passant ne sont que des générateurs de stabilisateurs XX
ou ZZ à 2 qubit cette fois, et on voit communément ces diagrammes tournés de
45°. Une autre classe intéressante de codes, qui tombe aussi dans la catégorie générale des codes topologiques, sont les codes
couleur. Je ne vais pas expliquer exactement comment ils fonctionnent, mais une façon de les concevoir est qu'ils sont des généralisations géométriques
du code de Steane à 7 qubit. Donc considérons le code de Steane à sept qubit et supposons qu'on numérote nos
qubit en utilisant la convention d'ordre KCET comme montré ici à l'écran. On peut alors associer ces sept
qubit aux sommets du graphe montré ici, et ce qu'on trouve, c'est que les générateurs de stabilisateurs correspondent
aux tuiles ou aux faces formées par les arêtes du graphe, et pour chaque tuile on a toujours un générateur de stabilisateurs Z
et un générateur de stabilisateurs X qui agissent de façon non triviale précisément sur ces qubit qui se trouvent aux sommets de cette
WEBVTT
tuile. C'est bien parce que, tout comme pour le code Tore, on a une localité géométrique pour ce code, donc on n'a pas besoin
de déplacer des qubit sur de longues distances pour mesurer les générateurs de stabilisateurs, et le fait que les générateurs de stabilisateurs Z et X agissent toujours de façon non triviale sur
exactement les mêmes ensembles de qubit est aussi bien pour des raisons liées au calcul quantique tolérant aux fautes, dont je vais
parler davantage dans la prochaine leçon. Les codes couleur sont des codes correcteurs d'erreurs quantiques qui généralisent ce
motif de base, où on fait essentiellement la même chose mais avec des graphes différents. Par exemple, voici un graphe avec
19 sommets qui fonctionne. Ça nous donne un code qui encode 1 qubit dans 19, et il se trouve qu'il a
une distance de cinq. On les appelle codes couleur soit dit en passant, parce que l'une des conditions requises sur le graphe est que les faces peuvent être colorées avec trois couleurs, ce qui signifie
qu'on peut colorier les faces avec trois couleurs et on n'a jamais deux faces de la même couleur partageant une arête. Les
couleurs n'ont pas vraiment d'importance pour le code lui-même, on a simplement des générateurs de stabilisateurs X et Z pour chaque face quelle que soit sa couleur, mais les couleurs
s'avèrent importantes pour analyser son fonctionnement. Donc voilà deux familles de codes très bien connues,
mais il existe beaucoup d'autres constructions connues, notamment celles qui sont basées sur des idées similaires à ces familles de codes ainsi que
des constructions complètement différentes. Un exemple spécifique de code correcteur d'erreurs quantiques qui a été récemment
découvert par certains de mes collègues chez IBM est connu sous le nom de code gross, ainsi nommé parce qu'une grosse est une douzaine
de douzaines, soit 144. En particulier, ce code encode 12 qubit dans 144 qubit et il a
une distance de 12. Je ne vais pas expliquer comment ce code fonctionne en détail. Il est similaire au code Tore, sauf que chacun des
générateurs de stabilisateurs implique maintenant deux qubit supplémentaires qui sont juste un peu plus éloignés. Il n'a pas d'immersion planaire
comme un surface code, mais il a une immersion dite bi-couche, ce qui signifie que deux couches de qubit sont nécessaires plutôt
qu'une. Il appartient à une famille de codes appelés codes bivariant bicycle, et ce qui est particulièrement remarquable à leur sujet, c'est
qu'ils sont bien plus efficaces que le code Tore ou un surface code dans le sens où beaucoup plus de qubit peuvent être encodés tout en tolérant simultanément
à peu près le même taux d'erreurs. Pour le code gross, 144 qubit supplémentaires sont nécessaires pour la mesure
du syndrome, donc le nombre total de qubit requis est 288, ce qui en fait un candidat très prometteur pour la technologie d'aujourd'hui
Et voilà qui conclut cette leçon, qui portait sur les constructions de codes correcteurs d'erreurs quantiques, notamment les codes CSS, le code Tore, et un
aperçu d'autres constructions de codes quantiques, notamment les surface codes et les codes couleur. J'espère que tu rejoindras la
prochaine et dernière leçon de la série sur le calcul quantique tolérant aux fautes, qui aborde le défi d'effectuer des
calculs sur des états quantiques encodés en utilisant des opérations et des composants de calcul qui sont eux-mêmes sujets aux
erreurs. Au revoir et à bientôt